ein wunderschöner more gewartet uns hier
in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft hätte
meine liebe freunde wir haben du hast
hier gar nichts zu tun das ist mein haus
das ist komplett weg
[Musik]
ok egal wir haben für heute eine menge
zu tun und eine menge auf der
to-do-liste meine lieben freunde denn
ihr durftet in der letzten folge
entscheiden was ich machen soll heute
und da haben fast alle gesagt ich soll
für balu eine hundehütte bauen von der
bauen wir heute eine hundehütte ihr
fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich hey luca
warum verlässt du dafür deine insel
dahinten das hat einen ganz einfachen
grund und zwar müssen wir noch ganz
hinten also nicht nach hier das wäre
schön sondern nach da ganz hinten zu
unserem wüsten dorf denn da waren
akazien bäume und ich brauch akazienholz
[Musik]
und hier vorne sind wir auch schon
angekommen meine lieben freunde das
weizen weg von ungefähr vier minuten den
ich hier zurückgelegt habe nur für zwei
akazienholz falltüren die ich ganz schön
finde ich liebe dieses spiel ich habe
glaube ich ein bisschen zu lang akazien
bäume gefällt aber nach vorne sehen wir
auch schon das wüsten dorf und dort
können wir uns dann eine runde schlafen
legen denn ich habe keine lust bei der
nacht über das meer zu fahren und wieder
auf irgendwelche komischen unterwasser
zombies zu stoßen
deswegen der ist sitzt immer noch da
fest ich euch auch nicht ich würde sagen
ich suche mir jetzt erst mal ganz kurz
da bedeutet schreiben leute 2 max hier
wo leute ich gehe jetzt einfach mal hier
vorne in den turm rein hier geht's grad
das habe ich gesehen ich muss aber es
sind monster wo sind denn die monster
großen dem monster wollen einfach nur
[Musik]
ich muss sich jetzt trotzdem hier raus
verjagen so zeigt jetzt können auch
schlafen gehen immer noch mit dem netter
reck in der hand wir haben uns seit der
höhlen episode noch kein mal so richtig
entleert ich habe auch noch die lohn
routen hier beispielsweise drin auch die
ganzen quad sachen und den knochen im
blog das heißt wir müssen am ende der
heutigen folge auch auf jeden fall die
kisten sortierung machen willst du ich
finde allerdings sagen dass wir uns mal
wieder zurück zu unserer in
[Musik]
lg
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass das klappt
was mache ich jetzt hier meinen sprung
hier unten rein war auf jeden fall habe
ich wollte mal gucken ob ich schaffe ich
würde sagen wir laufen mal wieder zurück
zu unserer insel beziehungsweise fahren
mit dem brötchen und ich blende euch
jetzt generell mal einfach eine time lab
sein wie ich die ganzen sachen für die
hundehütte besorgen
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde ich habe alles
fertig vorbereitet für die hundehütte
nehme auch noch einmal ganz kurz
eisenbach mit denn damit können wir
schon ein bisschen heile und ich werde
jetzt auch noch einmal ganz kurz
unten in unsere höhle gehen denn ich
benötige drei cobblestone und die habe
ich oben nicht mehr denn cobblestone
habe ich alle in der hölle verbaut diese
drei cobblestone fragt euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich luca wofür brauchst du
die sieht doch gar nicht schön aus bei
einer hundehütte ja sind auch nicht für
die hundehütte sondern für unseren braus
stand mir wurden nämlich auch in die
kommentare geschrieben locker macht ihr
doch mal endlich ein
von daher hier die drei cobblestone
unten und hier eine lohn gute dann haben
wir einen braus stand und diesen brauch
stand möchte ich erstmal er hat sich
gerade geschüttelt von sweet den
brauchst dann möchte ich auf jeden fall
hier oben in meinen baumhaus reinsetzen
ihm nicht genau hier vorne hin
am ende der folge werden wir auch die
ganzen kisten hier befüllen und jetzt
geht's endlich an die hundehütte meine
lieben freunde die möchte ich nämlich
hier vorne hinsetzen
jetzt habe ich keine angst mit der baum
ist weg und hier vorne kommt jetzt die
kleine hundehütte hin erst mal das
allerwichtigste der trinken hat der
kommt nämlich hierhin und die
eigentliche hütte die hatte ich
eigentlich hütte soll hier vorne
hinkommen da machen wir nicht so und
setzen dann hier vorne eben zwei treppen
so hin
damit wir hier die beiden dran setzen
können und hier vorne auch so zac und
hier auch sagen
[Musik]
vallourec da ich muss hier kurze treppe
hinsetzen das ist für die it steht der
auf seinem futternapf
das ist nicht dafür hier vorne die
letzte fichtenholz treppe auf jeden fall
dran dann haben wir nämlich hier einen
kleinen ort wobei du rein können
hierüber schieben wir ihnen gleich rein
und generell machen wir die fichtenholz
falltüren hier an den rand ihr merkt
schon ich mache eine menge mit
fichtenholz ich lieb dich einfach hier
vorne machen wir das gras auch noch kurz
weg hier noch und hier vorn und auch wie
können wir nämlich auch dann hochklappen
und hier kommen dann so ein bisschen das
dach hin hier du stets auch immer im weg
und jetzt hast mich auch noch nass
gemacht gerade die auf jeden fall die
ziegel treppen hin und hier auch noch
granit treppen das habe ich gerade unten
in der höhle noch mal ein bisschen
granit abgebaut
warte einfach ab hier vorne auf jeden
fall auch noch so eine treppe dran und
dann können wir hier noch so eine ziege
treppe und hier auch noch eine also soll
sie ein bisschen durcheinander sein
dann habe ich mir noch granitstufen und
ziegel stufen gemacht die können wir
hier oben jetzt beispielsweise einfach
mal so und so hinsetzen und dann hier
auf der anderen seite wieder so ein
bisschen verteilt sagt und zack dann
habe ich mir auch noch eisengitter
gemacht hier vorne denn die sollen hier
runter gehen und das soll so ein
bisschen ja so eine absperrung sein wo
man quasi sein halsband dran machen kann
das habe ich ja hier darf habe ich extra
hier so akazienholz teile gemacht denn
dann können wir hier so und so machen
und das ist es dann quasi auch schon das
war's das dann
was sagst du ja braucht soll ich dir
jetzt eine villa bauen oder was ich weiß
jetzt nicht ob einige eventuell erwartet
haben dass ich hier ein viertes haus
limbaugh für balu aber die sache ist
dass er halt eigentlich kein riesiges
haus braucht also die meiste zeit mit
mir unterwegs und im gegensatz zu den
bildern braucht er auch kein bett oder
irgendwie so kann ich dir jetzt nicht
hier an was bin ich denn da 1
verschieben
doch es geht gegen eine koje und alles
drin
ja das stimmt das ist jetzt auf jeden
fall die hundehütte von ballweg dem habe
ich jetzt eins aufs maul alter
irgendwann reicht's mir auch alle wissen
mich hier des todes alter und ich werde
mich nie du kriegst jetzt eine schelle
okay dann in der nächsten folge
allerdings muss ich mir jetzt auch noch
mal einige neue schilder kräften nämlich
acht stücke nicht sogar zu wenig mir
wurde die kommentare geschrieben dass
ich doch mal bitte eine ein schwarzes
brett machen soll mit zielen die ich in
diesem projekt noch habe da kommt dann
zb die tiere insel hin da kommt dann zum
beispiel die bauminseln hin wo wir unter
anderem auch ja ziehen bäume pflanzen
können die wo wir ja heute die setzlinge
mitgenommen haben dann platzierte vorne
noch ein schild mit der willicher insel
das hat mir nämlich der user namens
inferno und in die kommentare
geschrieben dass ich doch einfach alle
village auf eine insel sich ziehen
lassen kann dann kann ich noch ballouz
halsband wohl färben das hat mir der
liebe daniel geschrieben und das werde
ich hier auch noch anbringen dann wurde
mir auch noch geschrieben ich kann einen
fisch einnehmen also einen normalen
reimer und damit auf einen tisch
rechtsklick machen und dann kann ich
diesen fisch bei mir in den see setzen
dass auf jeden fall auf dem ziel das hat
mir der user gene
knox beschrieben dann haben wir auch
noch hinzieht und zwar die insel
reparatur 2.0 unter die erste insel
reparatur wurde mir nämlich geschrieben
lukas nationen der höhle am meinen wir
brauchen eine richtige insel reparatur
folge die wird auf jeden fall kommen
genauso wie dies die wie die vollendung
von der bahnstrecke da brauchen wir
nämlich auch noch ein bisschen zeit ihr
seht schon hier ist ordentlich was zu
tun
kein problem und das war es jetzt auch
schon mit unseren acht schilder meine
lieben freunde also dass da und ist ein
bisschen das schwarze brett von unserer
insel wo wir dann alle sachen
aufschreiben die wir noch zu tun haben
deswegen wenn jeder andere vorschläge
habt dann schreibt mir gerne unten die
kommentare ich würde allerdings sagen
ich mache jetzt sogar ganz kurze time
labs wie ich die kisten sortiere und um
funktioniere hinten ins baumhaus da ich
hier jetzt wirklich 17 minuten lang die
kisten sortierung gemacht habe und nur
item von a nach b bewegt habe habe ich
mir gedacht und erhalte ich euch während
dieser teilnetz einfach mal wieder mit
einem kleinen witz den ich raus gesucht
habe und zwar meine lieben freunde was
ist grau und kann nicht fliegen eine zu
fette taube wir beenden jetzt mal hier
die kisten sortierung style apps ich bin
fertig freunde ich habe gerade ungelogen
20 minuten lang meine ganzen kisten
sortiert ich kann es euch mal ganz kurz
erklären und zwar habe ich hier erst mal
eine rüstung ständer gemacht weil ich
noch so ein bisschen rüstung hatte wo
ich jetzt nicht gesagt hätte more die
schmeißt jetzt wecken sondern dies auch
teilweise verzaubert die habe ich mir
jetzt einfach hier hingestellt
diese beiden kisten hier sind komplett
leer da können wir jetzt gucken was wir
hier einen packen hier unten habe ich so
sehr wertvolle sachen die beispielsweise
eisen heime
nidda kloster und das ist eigentlich
sehr selten und daher nehme ich das gibt
es auch mal raus und packt das
beispielsweise hier vorne eine sehr
wertvolle kiste hier ist nämlich die
ganzen ärzte darin ihr seht ihr redstone
reisen smaragde diamanten kohle und
goldbarren falls ihr euch fragt warum
diesmal ein bisschen mehr geworden sind
ich habe mit diesem winter ja hier vorne
ein bisschen gehandelt und zwar seht ihr
schon ich habe mein ganzes papier vom
zuckerrohr in smaragde verwandelt und er
ist jetzt auch bibliothek art geselle
das heißt er kann ein bisschen mehr als
die anderen
hier habe ich einfach krimskrams sondern
braucht man einfach in minecraft da sind
zum beispiel der knochen blog drin und
richter oder ketten oder spinnen augen
so keine ahnung ich muss nicht extra
eine kiste für spinnen augen und das war
es dann eigentlich auch schon mit der
kisten sortierung in meinem kleinen
häuschen hier wir können dann auch noch
mal ganz kurz ebenso achtung hier zu
unserer verzauberung insel
beziehungsweise zauberinsel
rüberspringen denn dort hat sich auch
was getan ich habe nämlich diesem blog
ersetzt durch ein fass und dort kommt
das ganze lapislazuli nein das brauchen
wir hierfür um sachen zu verzaubern ich
habe auch 34 level deswegen sollten wir
das auf jeden fall demnächst mal machen
und das bietet sich dort hat einfach an
weil dann weniger gäste muss ich nicht
wieder extra hoch laufen und so weiter
und so fort hier vorne ist das
schiffchen hey wir können einfach mal
wie sie hat keinen bock auf mich nur
weil ich heute mal richtig produktiv war
jetzt in folge bestanden oft hast du
hast mich ne ich kann es ja auch keinem
recht machen also dass sie vorne ist ja
unser baumhaus das finde ich wirklich
sehr schön und idyllisch hier vorne und
da kommen jetzt auch einfach mal die
türen und schließen damit keine monster
reinkommen und hier zeige ich euch jetzt
mal ganz kurz was ich hier getan hat
hier ist ja der brau stand deswegen habe
ich passend dazu hier die steine hin
gepackt macht eigentlich gar keinen sinn
machen allerdings hier weiter hier ist
nämlich noch gar nichts drin da können
wir ein paar andere steine dann auch ein
packendes das ist ein bisschen so wie
stein ecke hier da hier so ein bisschen
mehr holz ist habe ich gedacht ist so
ein bisschen die holzdecke habe ich zum
beispiel dass hier getan das soll hier
allerdings nicht denn das kann ich mal
so ein bisschen wieder aufstocken denn
das kommt hier rein in die natur christi
sind zum beispiel setzlinge blue
in kisten etc und hier haben wir nichts
aber hier haben wir dafür da noch so ein
bisschen rüstung werkzeuge
ich habe eine viertelstunde lang auf
dieses spiel geguckt und items sortiert
ich kann es wirklich nicht mehr sehen
ich würde allerdings sagen meine lieben
freunde da er hier sogar schon den mond
eingeblendet seht dass ich die heutige
folge an der stelle jetzt auch beenden
es tut mir leid es ist heute eigentlich
so häufig in den kommentaren dass ich
auch man soll mich zu entschuldigen aber
solche folgen
sie sind halt einfach nicht spannend und
ich hoffe ihr verzeiht mir aber es
musste einfach mal sein wir haben auf
jeden fall die ganze kisten sortierung
jetzt hinter uns in der nächsten folge
möchte ich mit den inseln anfangen ich
möchte beispielsweise die tiere insel
bei und ich möchte die bauminseln und
ich möchte die willicher insel bauen
nicht bauen
ich bin komplett plemplem das den daumen
hoch unter dem video david es euch
gefallen hat abonniert main kanal welt
für die nächste folge minecraft mit luca
morgen schon um 20 uhr nicht verpassen
wollt und wir sehen uns dann wieder
[Musik]